a former minnesota police officer
charged with killing a young black man
is now on trial in minneapolis jurors
were shown body cam video of the moment
that kim potter shot 20-year-old dante
wright back in april the 26-year veteran
says she mistakenly grabbed her gun
instead of her taser
david schuman of our minneapolis station
that's wcco tv reports on the trial's
opening day or wright's mother tearfully
took the stand
he called me to tell me that he has been
pulled over in wednesday's emotional
testimony katie bryant recounted one of
her final conversations with her son
dante wright before he was shot and
killed by police on april 11th i am
body cam video shows bryant arriving at
the scene after wright's girlfriend
video called her from the car and showed
her wright's body i wanted to hold him
and i wanted to protect him because
that's what mothers do
police pulled right over for expired
license plate tags and an air freshener
hanging from his rear view mirror which
is illegal in minnesota and discovered
he had an outstanding warrant
video from officer kim potter's body cam
shows police attempting to arrest wright
before wright gets back in his car
potter then pulls out her gun and shouts
taser
before shooting right in the chest
this case is about the defendant
kimberly potter
betraying her badge and betraying her
oath
minnesota assistant attorney general
aaron eldridge argued that potter a
26-year veteran violated her firearms
training
by failing to recognize that she had
pulled her firearm from the right side
of her body instead of the taser on her
left
we trust them
to know
wrong from right
and left from right
the defense argued that while potter
made a mistake in grabbing her handgun
it was in defense of a fellow officer
who could have been killed if wright
drove away
and all mr wright had to do
was stop
potter is expected to take the stand
next week for cbs mornings i'm david
schuman in minneapolis minnesota